hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well Emanuel Kant towards the end of his
prom to any future metaphysics in the
section entitled solution of the general
question of the prom is going to issue a
challenge and then rule out certain ways
of addressing or responding to the
challenge so what is the challenge it's
essentially to make metaphysics into a
genuine science a visen shof and Khan
says nobody has managed to pull that off
up until now and he says if you want
proof of this
if anybody thinks himself offended he is
at Liberty to refute my charge by doing
what by producing anur by you know
leading forward a single
synthetic
proposition belonging to
metaphysics dogmatically AR priori and
so what are the important parts of this
we don't really need to worry about the
dogmatically uh descriptor there but
what what somebody has to do is show us
a single AR prior synthetic
proposition which belongs to metaphysics
itself not to say mathematics or pure
Natural Science but actual metaphysics
Kant earlier on in the work said yeah
we've got mathematics we've got Pure
Natural Science those are fine we
already know that they exist when we're
asking how are they possible we're not
saying are they possible but metaphysics
we haven't really had the kind of
progress that we need to make in it
until K says his critical project and
why is that the case well because as he
said a little bit earlier uh metaphysics
did not exist as a science nor can it be
gathered peac mail but its germ must be
fully preformed in critique so if you
want to prove that count is wrong then
you've got to
produce something that would fit this
bill and that you could do peace meal
and K is going to say something really
interesting after that he says there are
two things which in case the challenge
be accepted I must deprecate now what is
to deprecate something bit in this case
it's to put down so when we say somebody
is self deprecating we're saying oh they
put themselves down right in this case
Kant is happy to deprecate these two
approaches these two kinds of appeals
and what are they well one is what we
can call trifling Spiel right playing
around messing around we often say spiel
or or trifling about and here the
translation a little bit perhaps
misleading about
probability um which is V Shin kite and
conjecture mut Mas now I do want to
point out that Kant himself has engaged
in a bit of what he says is mut masong
earlier in the section preceding this
and identified it as such right he says
that's not part of science I'm inquiring
into something I know that I cannot
claim this to be metaphysics per se so
probability translated here V leite
another way of Translating that is ver
similitude right something that looks
like it's true it has the uh appearance
of truth but it's not really true or
certain and then conjecture you know
what literally what is you know piling
up up or measuring uh of our sentiment
our mot right and so that's one thing
that we're going to have to look at
maybe two things that we're going to
have to look at and then the other one
that Kant really doesn't like not just
in this work but throughout his works as
a whole is the as he calls it the magic
wand right you wave a magic wand
sometimes in philosophy we talk about
hand waving uh similarly when somebody
does do really have an argument they
just wave their hand the magic wand of
socalled sound Common Sense Gunda
mention
literally the understanding the common
understanding of human beings and you
know Common Sense is an English term
that we use but this mentioned fand is
used similarly in German generally
putting K aside when somebody appeals to
Common Sense you can bet that there's
something a bit suspect going on you
know Common Sense typically as Kant is
saying right here doesn't actually
convince everybody but accommodates
itself to personal
peculiarities very often people will
assert that what they are claiming is a
matter of Common Sense
when it's not if it was truly common
sense then all rational beings would in
fact immediately uh say yes that's
correct to it and that just isn't the
case so common sense is a bit of a
misnomer there so what does he actually
have to say about probability and
conjecture why is this a problem there's
really three main points so he says uh
for the former nothing can be more more
absurd than in metaphysics a philosophy
from Pure reason than to try to ground
our judgments upon probability and
conjecture why is this absurd because
everything that is to be cognized a
priori is announced as apodictically
certain and must be proved in this
way is
probability apodictic no it's just
probable it's it it could be this way it
seems like it's this way it's plausible
I bet that it's the case that's not the
same thing as being absolutely
certain so that's a little too Loosey
Goosey we might say he says we might as
well try to ground geometry or
arithmetic on conjectures that's not the
way we proceed with those two
mathematical disciplines so why the hell
would we do that with metaphysics it's
it's not a good idea to do do that then
he goes on and he says okay uh somebody
might raise an objection what about the
calculus of probabilities Kant is living
in a time when mathematics has advanced
uh far enough uh really from the time of
Pascal right to
Encompass predictions about things for
example about gambling about lotteries
and playing cards and dice and stuff
like that
if you've ever studied probability and
statistics which is usually how we're
putting these things together in
courses you know that there is a theory
of probability and there is a calculus
for it it get quite complicated at times
it's quite a interesting area to study
and this is a very important point we're
not actually saying that the realities
that we're working with are merely
probable when we're doing the theory of
probability as Kant says it does not
contain probable but perfectly certain
judgments what what kind of judgments
concerning the degree of the possibility
of certain cases and notice the
Assumption here under given uniform
conditions which in the sum of all
possible cases must infallibly happen
according to the rule though it's not
sufficiently determined as regards every
single instance so you know we throw
dice we can say oh you know we got Snake
Eyes you know ones on each of them a two
out of the possible 12 that we could
have on six-sided die right what's the
probability of that if you know how to
calculate this you immediately say 1 and
36 same as rolling two sixes 1 and 36
same with rolling two FS 1 and 36 how do
you know that because it's not something
that is merely probable it's actually
something certain so that's not a really
good
objection and then he talks about the
empirical
sciences and he says that you know
conjectures by means of what we
typically do induction right there's a
whole science of induction or theory of
induction and analogy drawing analogies
between things now Kant here doesn't
seem to mean what he's earlier called
analogy in part three of the proma he
means analogy in the way that we
typically understand where we apply what
we know about one case to something
similar over here and we say ah it's
probably going to go similarly like that
but I could be wrong well those are fine
for the empirical Sciences metaphysics
isn't an empirical science so this isn't
going to do us any good so we can rule
out relying on probability and
conjecture what about common sense you
know there's an entire school over in
Britain and Scotland uh that want to you
know base things on Common Sense and are
deriving metaphysics in that way by the
way they had adherence in in Germany and
in America so what about
that Kant says the appeal to Common
Sense is even more absurd so it's not
just absurd it's more absurd there's
less to base it on than with probability
and conjecture why when Concepts and
principles are said to be valid not in
so far as they hold with regard to
experience but outside the conditions of
experience it's fine to use whatever
we're going to call Common Sense for
things that are purely experiential but
if we're going to try to go beyond it
and in metaphysics it's not really going
to work why so K says well what is
common sense what do we mean when we use
this term so it's a faculty of
knowledge and use of
rules in as he says concetto in concrete
particular cases not in abstracto he
uses the Latin terms in his work in the
uh General Universal sense right he says
that for
example Common Sense can hardly
understand the rule that every event is
determined by means of its cause and it
can never comprehend it thus generally
it demands an example from experience
when it hears this rule means nothing
but what it always thought when a pain
was broken or kitchen utensil missing
great examples there probably coming
from conso and experience right then it
understands the principle and grants it
so common sense can't get us metaphysics
it can tell us stuff about the world you
know matters of prudence matters of
skill to use the language that Kant will
use in the
groundwork but it can't get us what we
want in metaphysics and he says that
it's really only of use when it can see
its rules confirmed by experience so it
can't really tell us about what goes
beyond experience or what conditions
experience either so he says that uh to
comprehend matters AR prior
independently of experience this is not
something for common sense this is
something that belongs to the
speculative understanding now
understanding there fand right so it's
not mention fand it's
speculative uh fand that we're working
with here and it lies Beyond the Horizon
of Common Sense and he says listen the
province of metaphysics is entirely
confined to this kind of knowledge what
goes beyond experience and so it's a bad
sign of common sense to appeal to it as
a witness it can't really form
any good
opinion and people look down on it with
contempt until they find themselves in
difficulties and then they appeal to it
so if you meant to use common sense in
the first place well then you would have
done that before and then he's going to
consider what could appear to some
people to be a third sort of appeal but
it's actually falling under the rubric
of common
sense so he says it's a common cuge of
those false friends of Common Sense who
occasionally prize it highly but usually
despise it to say that there must be
some propositions immediately certain
and so you know in German
in that we can say say ah I know this
absolutely I don't need something else
to prove it there's no occasion to give
any proof or even account because
otherwise we could never stop inquiring
into the grounds of our judgments and
this is a way to try to address
skepticism we say well there's there's a
lot of things we can doubt and be you
know unclear about but there's got to be
some things that we know for certain
right otherwise we're we're kind of
screwed we can't get
anywhere with our knowledge of things
because not none of our knowledge is
really
reliable well what would be a candidate
for that and notice the examples that he
uses here he doesn't you know bring up
for example you know day carts I exist
uh or I think therefore I exist right
instead he brings up the principle of
what we call non-contradiction typically
in English but is often called just the
principle of contradiction meaning that
a thing cannot be and be in the same way
at the same time right and okay that's
good maybe maybe that is in fact a
absolutely certain proposition but what
are you going to get from that what can
you do with that it's not going to get
you
anything
empirical it's not going to get you a
priori synthetic propositions coming
from that you can get analytic
propositions as Kant discussed much much
earlier in the work from that but
that's not metaphysics proper is it
that's just a sort of side note that
helps you clarify
metaphysics and you know he says that's
not sufficient to show the truth of uh
synthetic
judgments what else well maybe
mathematical propositions such as twice
to make four between two points there's
but one straight line and he says that's
fine that's nice that ain't
metaphysics so what good is that going
to do you
to do mathematics we've already got
mathematics that we already know that
works that exists you know that is
certain that doesn't get you a prior
synthetic judgments that are
metaphysical which is what the challenge
was about wasn't it so he goes on and he
says um I can't by all the power of my
thinking extract from the concept of a
thing the concept of something else
whose existence is necessarily con
connected with the former but I have to
call upon experience and though my
understanding furnishes me a priori the
concept of such a connection that is
causation I can't exhibit it a priori
intuition like I can the concepts of
mathematics and therefore show its
possibility uh priori so he says
therefore in metaphysics as a
speculative science of pure reason we
can never appeal to common sense but may
do so only when in certain matters we
are forced to surrender it and renounce
all speculative cognition which must
always be theoretic knowledge therefore
we're forced to forego metaphysics
itself and it's instruction for the sake
of adopting a rational Faith which may
alone be possible for us sufficient to
our wants and then the shape of the
thing he says is quite altered you're no
longer doing
metaphysics as a science and he says
metaphysics has to be a science not just
in its parts but in its whole as a
totality so if you're going to have
genuine
metaphysics can't use common sense you
can't appeal to that nor can you rely on
uh probability and conjecture neither of
these are going to be ways in which we
can achieve a genuine metaphysics that
Kant wants us to
actually do which he's trying to provide
himself by using critique as his own
tool for
that